it's defund forever for the radical left
as president biden and other democrats
desperately try to get away from the
movement that is political kryptonite
squad member corey bush whose own car
got riddled with bullets during the
crime wave is refusing to stop using the
slogan ahead of the midterms saying
quote to fund the police is not the
problem we dangled the carrot in front
of people's faces and said we can get it
done and that democrats deliver
when we haven't totally delivered
meantime the liberal crime free for all
continues who needs to worry about by
inflation when you can just steal to
your heart's content the new york post
capturing this guy nabbing 10 stakes
from a trader joe's i don't know judge
if i my ride got riddled with bullets i
might think twice about the funding
police well you know when she was asked
that question not that specific one but
when she was asked you know about the
hypocrisy of it all and i'm so tired of
using that word i want to like put it
away for the rest of the year but when
she was asked you spent over 300 000 for
your own security her response to that
is you want to see me dead is that what
you want you want to see me dead her
life is more important than everyone
else that's what people don't understand
but so you have to say to yourself what
is going on here what is going on that
we're masking our kids when we know that
they're emotionally suffering as a
result of it what is going on that the
mom and pop stores are being shut down
the big box stores are being saved you
know like what is going on when you've
got truckers all over the world now
you've got canada you've got the united
states france other countries
people are saying we want to be able to
work we want to be able to live our
lives in freedom and we want law and
order and these people who brought in
this social justice nonsense have ruined
it the truth is we knew how to fight law
order we knew it a long time ago and now
they want to just eliminate it and talk
about defunding police while other
people die last point i'd like to know
in the inner city in new york city and
any other city how many how many uh
people of color have died as a result of
taking out street time street crime
units or anti-crime units you know what
is the impact on real people as opposed
to these criminals running around or a
guy with 16 priors
for robbery assault and burglary takes a
baseball bat winds himself up and beats
an asian woman across the head from
behind she's got a fractured skull
unconscious in several places who knows
if she'll live he's been charged with 16
other crimes look at him right there
wyatt and greg he went out after bashing
her skull in and grabbed a slice of
pizza what is with this attack on asians
i mean we it's the one we the media used
to talk about this when they thought
they had the the appropriate narrative
that they liked and then all of a sudden
the races change you can't no one brings
it up but it is overwhelming how many
times you hear about asian elderly asian
asian women it's it's really a black
perpetrator
yeah yeah i mean it's like it's it's
insane anyway
i'm mad at the new york post for not
using the the correct headline which
would have been the purloiner of the
sirloin
uh this has gotta really i gotta see the
guy without the mask that might have
been you by the way i saw you eat ribs
look you know who's really upset about
this
the day after mayor adams tries to push
veganism what happens here's a guy
that's stealing a stack of steaks i'm
talking about a slap in the face with a
t-bone i mean it's like it's like why
aren't you stealing plant-based foods
why don't you do that meanwhile i mean
and the other thing too is
tom cotton was is investigating this
arson sentence for this guy set fire to
a pawn shop killed a person got a
lenient sentence a sentence cut in half
because it happened during the george
floyd riots so what's the lesson hey if
you want a better chance of getting away
with a crime like murder maybe do it in
a media or a democrat approved
insurrection but if you try anything
like in a riot in dc on january 6 if you
happen to walk in you're going to get
five years
and this d.a here bragg what's going on
with him did he walk it back is he
scared which part the you mean his memo
yeah this crazy guy yeah i think that
he's here i think that he has realized
that that's it's not going to fly you
said something the first day we talked
about him you said new york will never
stand for that no we won't and i
remember because i'm fairly new to new
york right i've only lived i've lived
here 10 years but it feels like i'm new
but when you said that i thought oh okay
um i can see that where people are like
no we're not going to deal with this in
this way and greg pointed out to me in
the green room that al sharpton is now
complaining about the crime and saying
and asking the mayor to do something
really say one thing about corey it's al
sharpton and bill maher and the five
we're all in agreement on everything
yeah and why is sharpton mad why because
they he they lo it is dwayne reed they
lock up the toothpaste yeah wait what oh
that's why you know what he has a point
he has a point he has a point said that
everything's locked up have you gone to
buy toiletries recently
we have to beat something and then you
have to say you know can someone help me
that's why you just ordered files yeah
al sharpton is one of the smartest
people in public life i tell you i've
known it forever he is geraldo i have to
cut you off
i think defund the police is the gift
the democrats have given the republicans
they won't stop giving i mean it is
absolutely preposterous
it is why they almost lost congress last
time around it's why they're going to
lose congress this time around if they
can focus on
republicans can stay focused uh you know
i really think that what we need is we
need more cops we need more minority
cops we need better paid cops we need
stop question and frisk back uh and we
we need to
hold store owners like trader joe's
responsible when they intentionally
allow a thief to walk out and they do
nothing to stop it that only perpetuates
this this misery uh and adds to the uh
to this epidemic they're afraid of being
sued but but they should get sued by a
municipality i agree or for encouraging
creating a climate of lawlessness
everybody sees everybody did you ever
want to say well i just want to say
about cory bush real quick
the reason that the democrats are having
to figure out a way to distance
themselves from her is because speaker
pelosi gave her so much clout right in
the beginning when remember when she
stayed the night on the capitol steps
and she wanted the illegal eviction
moratorium to be extended and biden said
there's we can't do this and everybody
knew that that would be the end result
they still allowed her to do that that's
why she has the platform that she has
they gave her
all right yeah trader joe's will be
there in a little bit
not plant-based coming for the meat hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else